[Musique]
bonjour je suis ravi de vous retrouver
ici depuis bruxelles depuis le coeur du
parlement européen
dans ce nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo
bien nous allons ouvrir ensemble les
portes de l'europe
et voici le programme la confrontation
diplomatique et commerciale entre la
chine et les états unis ne cessent de
s'intensifier au sein de ses relations
internationales quelle peut être la
place le rôle de l'union européenne les
européens peuvent-ils éviter de choisir
un camp comment s'affirmer face aux deux
puissances mondiales des questions que
je poserai à mes invités en plateau mais
avant
retour sur ces manifestations un peu
partout en europe déclenchées par la
mort de georges floyd cet américain noir
asphyxié par un policier blanc à
minneapolis les dizaines de milliers
d'européens sont descendus dans la rue
pour dénoncer le racisme et les
violences policières c'est un sujet de
jonathan du prix m
[Musique]
la vie des noirs comptent scandaient ces
manifestants à edimbourg sous la statue
d'henri dundas figures politiques du
xviiie siècle
accusée d'avoir freiné l'abolition de
l'esclavagé ils réclament le
déboulonnage du monument nous n'avons
pas besoin que ses statuts soient
codifiées ici pour quoi faire
qu'est ce qu'elle enseigne si vous
voulez d'enseignés pas dans les livres
d'histoire pensez vous vraiment que
quelqu'un va les regarder et apprendre
l'histoire ce que cette personne a
réellement fait donc bien sûr elles
n'ont pas besoin d'être là les scènes
comme celle ci se sont multipliées en
europe dans le sillage de la mort de
georges floyd aux états unis en belgique
notamment près de bruxelles
des activistes ont vandalisé déboulonner
un buste de léopold ii à quelques jours
des 60 ans de l'indépendance du congo
le mr didier gosuin espère rétablir le
buste à condition de contextualiser son
histoire au moyen d'une plaque
s'il ya une contextualisations elle sera
remise dans le cas contraire les
tensions seront toujours vive que
ça une autre bande d'individus masqués
reviendront se livrer à du vandalisme
donc cette séchant fin pour dépassionner
les questions mémorielles les allemands
peut être trouvé la solution
ce musée à berlin exposé des dizaines de
statues polémique de toutes époques
ici l'histoire pose un cadre au débat la
question c'est que faire avec les
statuts des montées est ce qu'on les met
dans un musée est ce qu'on les jette à
l'eau nous avons je pense une solution
pour les pièces dites toxiques
on les met dans un musée mais ce n'est
pas pour autant que c'est terminé nous
excusons ces objets ici pour que les
gens puissent continuer à s'en
préoccuper et dans un contexte différent
en france plusieurs monuments ont aussi
été vandalisée comme ici colbert devant
l'assemblée nationale le président de la
république avait condamné tout ré
écriture fausses ou haineuses du passé
craignant qu'il ne renforce le
communautarisme
[Musique]
et j'accueille sur ce plateau younous
omarjee euro députés français la france
insoumise vous siégez donc ici au
parlement européen sein du groupe de la
gauche unitaire bonjour bienvenue
je voudrais d'abord avoir votre
sentiment votre réaction à ces
manifestations à bristol à copenhague à
bruxelles un peu partout en europe
est-ce que vous vous attendiez à autant
de mobilisation citoyenne spontanée en
europe et dans le monde
c'est un déferlement suite à aux chocs
qu'a provoqué l'assassinât de georges de
floride beaucoup sont surpris et
effectivement il y a une
un étonnement devant la mobilisation
planétaire mais il faut toujours
percevoir les courants profonds qui
traversent les sociétés est en réalité
cela fait des années et des années que
beaucoup de problèmes sont posés par des
militants antiracistes par les minorités
ces problèmes n'étaient pas entendues
ont fermé les yeux et voilà qu'il faut
irruption sur la scène publique est en
soi c'est très intéressant
ce qui explique selon vous cette
résonance si forte en europe à cette
mort qui a eu lieu à des milliers de
kilomètres puisque elle a eu lieu aux
états ou bien sûr parce que la mort de
georges floyd comme je le disais en
plénière renvoi des siècles de
domination des noirs aux états unis mais
elle renvoie aussi aux inégalités de
conditions en europe et nous savons
qu'il y a en europe des inégalités
sociales qui se superposent sur
l'appartenance aux rasses si on peut
utiliser ce terme et en écho également
au parlement européen puisque c'est là
suscité de nombreuses réactions
transpartisane d'ailleurs il ya eu un
débat dans l'hémicycle au cours duquel
une de vos collègues pierrette
hassberger fofana eurodéputée allemande
écologiste d'origine malienne affirme
avoir été victime la veille à bruxelles
de violences policières joe drake on
écoute hier en sortant de la gare du
nord j'ai vu neuf policiers harcelé deux
jeunes noirs
j'avais mon téléphone en main j'ai fait
une photo de la scène avec mon téléphone
ce qui est légal les policiers se sont
dirigés vers moi ils m'ont arraché mon
téléphone des mains quatre des neuf
policiers armés m'ont brutalement poussé
contre le mur ils ont violemment pris
mon sac à main ils m'ont plaqué au mur
jambes écartées et un policier voulais
me tester me fouiller
ils m'ont traitée de façon humiliante
quand j'ai dit aux policiers que j'étais
député au parlement aux ports européens
il ne m'a pas cru nous devons donc
prendre des mesures concrètes pour bon
nombre de personnes qui ne sont pas ici
et qui n'ont pas pu échapper à la
violence policière
je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je précise tout de même que la police
belge conteste la version des faits et
qu'est ce qu'elle raconte votre collègue
allemand d'une banalisation des
violences policières du racisme dans nos
sociétés européennes
que l'on soit eurodéputés ou pas
d'ailleurs bien sûr elle raconte le
quotidien de millions et de millions
d'offres descendants mais aussi de
maghrébins de roms en europe qui sont
victimes de discriminations et de
violences policières et aussi judiciaire
je crois aujourd'hui en france mais
aussi dans beaucoup de pays européens
lorsque vous êtes noir ou lorsque vous
êtes arabe
vous êtes toujours un peu plus suspect
moi même lorsque je prends le train pour
venir à bruxelles
je suis régulièrement victime de
contrôle de police j'interroge mes
collègues et ils me disent que jamais
ils ne sont victimes de vols par les
douanes et la police donc je m'interroge
et d'évidence il s'agit de contrôles au
faciès
donc au delà de nos propres personnes ce
que ma collègue exprime c'est en réalité
et c'est ce que nous disons dans la
résolution que nous avons adopté des
situations de racisme structurel et il
faut s'interroger sur cela pour pouvoir
combattre véritablement les
discriminations alors durant ce débat
dans l'hémicycle la présidente de la
commission revêt niort cela van der
leyen a également pris la parole
on écoute je n'ai jamais fait
l'expérience d'être traitées
différemment à seule raison de raison de
mon apparence
je ne sais pas ce que c'est que d'être
traité avec soupçons
jour après jour dans la rue ou en
faisant mes courses à la recherche d'un
emploi ou d'un nouveau logement
comme notre collègue nous a tous
justement raconté incroyable la plupart
d'entre nous dans cette salle ne le
savent pas il est grand temps de faire
plus qu'écouter plus
condamné il est temps de parler du
racisme ouvertement et honnêtement on
entend les mots très forts d'ursula von
der leyen a alors lu nioro et l'union
européenne quand est-ce qu'elle fasse
concrètement à l'action pour lutter
contre le racisme
d'abord je dis bravo à la présidente de
la commission
j'étais en plénière le discours qu'elle
a prononcé est un discours aujourd'hui
impossible dans beaucoup d'états membres
et en france en particulier amont ou en
bois parce que si vous l'avez bien
écoutez elle dit je ne sais pas ce que
c'est et je vais formuler des
propositions par rapport à ce
qu'expriment celles et ceux qui sont
victimes du racisme et j'ai sein des
institutions européennes iliad il ya du
racisme il ya un manque de diversité
mais évidemment au sein même des
instituts clairement et c'est ce racisme
là qui est intéressant ce racisme
raffiné non pas le racisme bête et
méchant de personnes dont on attend
finalement des attitudes racistes mais
vous avez toujours cette forme de
condescendance parfois de paternalisme
qui renvoie à tout un continent au
mental et c'est tout ce continent mental
qu'il faut extirper et qu'il faut
connaître pour pouvoir lutter
véritablement contre leur assiette
comment on fait avec des partis
xénophobes et racistes qui engrange de
nombreuses en europe dans ce parlement
européen
nous avons tous la conscience de la
gravité du danger pour l'europe
l'histoire de l'europe c'est toujours un
basculement inquiétant entre la barbarie
et la civilisation n'oublions jamais que
l'horreur nazie
le low cost est né en europe il n'y a
pas si longtemps que cela et je constate
qu'il ya une montée du fascisme une
montée des partis xénophobes nous
l'avons vu pour les élections
européennes
et c'est pourquoi la réponse de tous les
démocrates dans ce parlement européen
est forte et unie elle reste que les 1
sitution européenne avant 2020 elles
sont prêtes à se remettre en cause
nous attendons qu'elles le soient
véritablement parce que regarder la
commission von der leyen
c'est une commission qui a essayé
d'atteindre des objectifs sur la parité
hommes-femmes
mais qui en revanche est totalement en
manque de diversité
idem dans les institutions européennes
il faut que ce parlement soit l image de
la société européenne les sociétés
auront de l'union européenne sont
aujourd'hui des sociétés
multiculturelles et cela est
malheureusement pas très représentés ici
merci marc agit on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler on fasse un tout autre sujet
très vaste
quelle place pour l'union européenne sur
la scène diplomatique alors que les
tensions se multiplient entre la chine
et les etats unis comment l'europe
peut-elle tirer son épingle du jeu avec
une difficulté supplémentaire dans
l'équation l'allié historique américain
souffle le chaud et le froid écouter les
sorties du président américain donald
trump
j'accueille anna cavadini bonjour vous
êtes eurodéputée verte allemande efface
avoue nathalie l'oiseau vous êtes
eurodéputés français dans le groupe
renault et je précise que vous êtes
présidente de la commission sécurité et
défense
on vient d'entendre le président
américain qui n'est pas toujours tendre
avec l'europe c'est moi qu'on puisse
dire il a d'ailleurs été un fervent
partisan du break site
nathalie l'oiseau donald trump et ils
anti-européen donald trump avait fait
campagne en 2016 en disant america first
amérique d'abord et puis en fait ce
qu'il a déroulé depuis quatre ans et
l'amérique tout seul contre le reste du
monde
c'est quelqu'un qui ne croient pas aux
alliances même les plus importantes même
les plus fortes comme l'alliance
transatlantique
mais attention c'est le style trump
c'est la présidence 30
mais il ya quelque chose de plus profond
soit obama on avait déjà parlé d'un
pivot des etats-unis vers l'asie avec un
intérêt moindre vers l'europe
je pense qu'on doit faire attention de
ne pas se dire en novembre s'il y a un
nouveau président américain tout va
revenir comme avant
je pense que d'une manière générale les
états unis sont aujourd'hui moins
appliquée en europe et que nous devons
arrêter de demander ce que font les
états unis pour nous mais nous prendre
en charge nous mêmes
halak avait dit donald trump il critique
un beau coup les européens sur le plan
commercial les menaces de droits de
douane augmenté sur certains produits
comme les automobiles reviennent
régulièrement c'est le point de discorde
principale selon vous entre les états
unis et l'union européenne
oui comme vous avez dit c'est vraiment
quelque chose qu'on a vu depuis trente
élus il menace toujours
l'union européenne avec les droits de
douane ce pour coup à monter politique
par exemple
le taxes des entreprises numériques ou
aussi pour diminuer notre standard
d'agriculteurs y moi je crois vraiment
que l'union européenne doit pas céder à
cette chantage la l'union ne revienne
toi m rester forte et point est pour
l'instant l'europe elle reste forte
selon vous face et aux états unis a pour
l'instant et je crois durablement
l'europe est unie le meilleur promoteur
de l'unité de l'union européenne c'est
donald trump tous ceux qui tous les
nationalistes qui nous disait on serait
mieux seule phase on reste du monde ont
la démonstration éclatante que seul on
est beaucoup moins fort qu'à 25 et
aujourd'hui cette démonstration on la
voit avec le break site
pourquoi est ce que dans une shop est
tellement favorable aux briques site
c'est parce qu'ils pensent que il aura
les meilleures conditions pour écraser
le royaume uni on sait qu'aujourd'hui
dans la négociation entre le royaume uni
et les etats unis
les etats unis sont en train de forcer
les britanniques à baisser leurs
standards alimentaire a baissé leurs
standards agricole ça n'aurait pas été
possible si le royaume uni était restée
dans le noir c'est le mauvais alors
justement brixi d'un lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique conflit israélo
palestinien les sujets d accord ils sont
ils sont nombreux il ya également la
question de la défense européenne les
états unis ont annoncé il ya quelques
jours le retrait d'une partie de leurs
troupes
dix mille soldats sous l'égide de l'otan
qui vont quitter l allemagne une partie
sera redéployée vers la pologne
c'est un sujet de plus de dix corps tout
d'abord à va avoir votre réaction à
cavadini je crois que à la fin va faire
mettre son pays même de mauvais les
troupes en allemagne parce que on
normalement je crois que les états unis
ont besoin de cette base militaire pour
s'entraîner à l'autre pays plus de l'est
donc moi je crois que allah dès la fin
c'est mal pour son propre pays c'est
vécu comme en allemagne
je crois que en allemagne et à 2
point de vue je crois qu'il ya quelques
ann moi qui pense oui ça fait du temps
que le les états unis retraite de
l'allemagne parce que c'est oui la
guerre la seconde guerre mondiale ça
fait beaucoup de temps pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a encore quelques troupes en
allemagne et l'autre partie dit ah oui
c'est mal parce que oui on a encore un
très forte relation avec états unis et
son palais avec le gouvernement allemand
a annoncé ça ça vraiment un peu mal
nathalie l'oiseau est ce que cela
relance l'idée d'une europe de la
défense voire d'une armée européenne
si ça ne nous réveille pas qu'est ce
qu'il nous faudra aujourd'hui dans
l'otan on a deux difficultés
la première c'est le comportement des
états unis et on a vu qu'en partie ce
transfert de troupes de l'allemagne vers
la pologne dans le shop l'avaient
décidée pour donner un coup de pouce
électorale de dernière minute au
président polonais donc c'est une
ingérence et une interférence
arrêtons-nous plein organisons en fait
qu'est-ce qu'il ya des sujets sur
lesquels les états unis et l'union
européenne sont d'accord je crois que
c'est un petit peu la chine parce que
oui européenne et dans les états unis on
voit quelques problèmes avec la chine
mais je crois que les instruments qui
utilise son différend avec l'union
européenne a commencé une guerre
commerciale avec la chine mais à l'autre
côté l'union européenne a vraiment un
décidé de prendre un autre chemin et ça
c'est devenu quelques instruments de
défense commerciale
alors justement vous parlez la chine je
voudrais qu'on écoute un mic pompéo qui
le chef de la diplomatie américaine mike
pompéo et josep borrell son équivalent
en europe qui vont entamer de nouvelles
discussions pour tenter d'apaiser leurs
relations est-ouest shirt de recrues
avec itunes nathalie l'oiseau est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec ce que disait
anna camadini finalement ce qui
rassemble les
ats-unis l'union européenne c'est
peut-être la chine un ennemi commun sur
l'analyse oui c'est à dire notamment la
préoccupation sur les droits de l'homme
sur le sens des ouigours sur ce qui se
passe à hong kong
on voit les choses de la même façon
après sur la manière de se comporter
les etats unis se sont lancés dans une
nouvelle guerre froide vis-à-vis de la
chine
comme si on pouvait du jour au lendemain
décider que on écoutait plus la chine
ont dialogué plus avec la chine on ne
coopérait pas avec la chine
ça n'a pas de sens alors justement sur
le front chinois l'union européenne
tente là aussi d'apaiser les tensions il
ya eu un sommet dernièrement qui pour le
moment n'a pas abouti mais le président
du conseil reconnaissait l'importance 1
du partenaire chinois je le cite le
volume des échanges quotidiens entre la
chine et l'union européenne représente
un milliard d'euros par jour la chine
évidemment est un partenaire
incontournable anna calvi ni oui la
chine est vraiment très important mais
c'est quand on voit maintenant la chine
ceux-ci de vraiment très forte ces
entreprises il s'est trop ça il n'y a
pas une concurrence juste entre les
entreprises européennes et la chine
et c'est pour ça que l'union européenne
à développer quelques instruments pour
se protéger de la chine
je crois que c'est aussi entre ça c'est
le débat sur le coup vite 19
parce que maintenant beaucoup de
personnes en europe disent ok peut-être
en toi re-localiser quelques produits y
ait quelques chaînes de production plus
en europe loi être moins dépendants au
shin alors vous parlez des règles de la
concurrence
l'union européenne elle souhaite plus
d'équité 1 dans ses relations avec la
chine et tente donc de faire bouger les
lignes a notamment dans les règles de
concurrence
explications avec jonathan du prix s
[Musique]
comment protéger le marché unique de la
concurrence étrangère déloyale la
commission européenne s'est attaquée à
cette question à l'heure où de
nombreuses entreprises de l'ue eux ont
été très affaibli lors de la crise
sanitaire le marché unique est la clé de
la prospérité européenne mais cela ne
fonctionne que si les règles du jeu sont
équitables et pour les commissions il
est prioritaire de protéger ces
conditions de concurrence équitables
contre les dommages que peuvent causer
les subventions étrangers à bruxelles
vise principalement les entreprises
chinoises soupçonnaient d'avoir
largement profité de la crise de 2008
pour investir en europe à bas prix pour
limiter la concurrence étrangère
déloyale bruxelles planche ainsi sur une
batterie de mesures
s'il est avéré qu'une entreprise
étrangère a un effet néfaste sur la
concurrence du marché unique lieu
pourrait exiger des paiements
compensatoires en contrepartie bruxelles
pourrait aussi poser une sorte de droit
de veto sur une acquisition étrangère
dans le marché unique ou encore durcir
les conditions d'attribution aux marchés
publics européens sans toutefois tourné
le dos aux investissements étrangers ou
aux accords de libre échange
la commission européenne espère sortir
de la naïveté
selon les mots de margrethe vestage
heures une manière pour l'europe de
s'affirmer sur fond de guerre
commerciale avec la chine et les états
unis
est-ce que l'as nathalie oiseaux c'est
un vrai changement que la commission
tente d'impulser ici alors ça fait trois
ans que la france mettait ce sujet sur
la table quand j'étais au gouvernement
ça faisait partie de nos sujets la
surveillance des investissements
étrangers dans les secteurs stratégiques
en europe
la réciprocité se moque on n'osait pas
prononcé il a fallu une pandémie
mondiale
il a fallu des pénuries de masques de
respirateurs il a fallu la crainte que
des entreprises européennes fragilisées
soit rachetée dans des conditions
opaques par des entreprises non
européennes notamment chinoises pour que
ce que nous avions dit depuis plusieurs
années finissent par être partagée
c'est la fin de l'innocence de l'année
l'euro qui veut se faire respecter il
faut pas craindre une réponse chinoise
face à ces nouvelles heures
la commission tente de mettre en oeuvre
il y aura comme dans toute négociation
du bluff détention mais ce qu'il faut
craindre beaucoup plus c'est de ne rien
faire
le statu quo on a vu où il nous
conduisait on l'a déjà vu dans la crise
de 2008 2011
souvenez vous quand on a vu le port du
pirée en grèce
racheté par la chine ça a été un moment
de réveil
maintenant on a en place des instruments
une volonté politique on n'a pas envie
d'entrer dans une guerre avec la chine
et on veut discuter d'égal à égal mais
ya pas d état qui joue un peu le double
jossin l'union européenne qui à la fois
vous sous son sur cette île à mais qui
laisse les chinois à investir
massivement dans leurs pays en comme
toujours et un problème que l'union
européenne quelque fois ne pas à pas
avec une voix aussi 30
cette stratégie de chantage et oui et la
chine c'est la même chose
par exemple le oui avec le par exemple
une promesse quelques investissements en
république tchèque ou aussi en italie
pour wii mettre ces pays à son côté mais
je crois que la force de l'union
européenne étaient toujours qu'on a
parlé avec une voix et je crois que ça
c'est super important de rester ensemble
et de lui faire la même stratégie
alors comment on fait pour mieux
encadrer ces investissements chinois au
sein de l'europe là on parlait en effet
de l'aqmi tchèque ou l'italie on a un
sujet avec la hongrie qui a profité de
la loi sur l'urgence sanitaire pour
faire passer quelque chose qui n'avait
pas grand chose à voir avec le co vide
qui était le projet de train entre
budapest et belgrade en partenariat avec
la chine
ba aujourd'hui on a ce réseau d' alerte
on doit aussi réfléchir à ce que nous
faisons au niveau européen pendant trop
longtemps la politique de la concurrence
elle a surtout contribué à porter
atteinte à des champions leur père
une société européenne ne pouvait pas en
racheter une autre parce que elle
risquait de devenir un quasi monopole
mais quand on fasse et des géants
chinois américains d'autres nationalités
il faut qu'on apprenne à se renforcer
retrouver la souveraineté européenne on
en parle beaucoup en ce moment en tout
cas dans la bouche du président français
emmanuel macron vous êtes d'accord avec
sanaa cavadini c'est quoi la
souveraineté européenne et a pour moi la
souverainété être capable de réaliser
ses valeurs et ses valeurs c'est pour
moi aussi le recruter contre le
changement climatique les trois humaines
les standards sociaux
il s'est pas seulement la défense parce
que si on pense on sait que souveraineté
en brosse très vite à la défense mais je
crois que les valeurs sûres beaucoup
plus plus grande et je crois que
défendre ses valeurs comme lutter contre
le changement climatique
ça c'est la souveraineté pour moi mais
les valeurs et nous maire sait ce que
c'est compatible notamment avec avec la
chine je crois qu'il faut qu'on sorte
d'un débat qui par exemple en france me
paraît souvent mal engagée en france on
est très hostile au libre échange ne
change pas mal pourquoi est-ce qu'on
signe des accords mais quand on signe
des accords dans l'union européenne
signe de désaccord c'est précisément
l'occasion pour elle d'imposer ses
normes ses standards et ses préférences
qu'est ce qu'on préfère la loi de la
jungle où tout le monde fait ce qu'il
veut ou utiliser notre toit le plus
grand marché solvable du monde pour dire
vous voulez commercer avec nous ben nous
on veut réguler ce commerce
on veut des normes environnementales
sociales on est d'accord mais dans ces
accords ont négocié donc on l'a vu aussi
que face au canada face au brésil
mercosur etc eh bien il ya du pain il ya
eu parfois il a fallu trouver un
consensus et on attaque c'est l'union
européenne d'avoir été d'avoir justement
à baisser ses standards
moi je crois qu'il faut pour n'évolue là
dessus je pense que l'on fera le bilan
d'ici quelque temps de ce que donne le
ceta avec le canada sur le mercosur
à titre personnel mais c'est aussi le
cas de ma délégation en l'état moi je ne
ratifierait pas le mercato parce qu'on a
en face de nous un président brésilien
qui ne croit pas au changement
climatique qui massacrent l'amazonie
avec lequel on ne peut pas dire vous
êtes la bonne personne pour signer un
accord ce n'est pas vrai entre la chine
et les états unis l'union européenne
sera t-elle obligé de choisir un camp
pas de choisir mais de trouver soi même
chemin et je crois que le schéma
européenne et une décoration de
multilatéralisme mais aussi c'est
vraiment il ya mettre ces valeurs dont
l'outil de taurus réalisme il est
commerce les accords de libre commerce
en ce moment là pour moi sont pas
parfaits ils toit est révolu d'envoi
avec le mercosur il n'y a pas de stand
up efficace doit aller plus loin il faut
être plus exiger poiret leurs exigences
notamment sur les accords de libre
échange est ce que l'union européenne
elle peut envisager d'être un
intermédiaire un médiateur entre entre
la chine et l'union européenne entre la
chine et les états unis croient d'abord
qu'elle doit pas être l'otage de cette
montée de tension
elle doit rester elle même parce qu'il
ya des attentes fortes y compris dans le
reste du monde
si on regarde ce qui s'est passé sur la
pandémie du collier pourra toujours dire
que des choses qui auraient dû être
mieux anticiper mieux organisés c'est
vrai mais regardez aujourd'hui en europe
l'aide qui a été donné par l'union
européenne pour le chômage partiel
vous ne la trouvez pas aux états unis
vous ne la trouvez pas en chine
la transparence le débat y compris les
critiques sur la manière dont on a géré
la crise du coc vide
vous ne trouverez jamais en chine je
trouve que cette crise là encore nous
permet de nous dire avec nos
imperfections
notre modèle est capable de faire face
il est capable d'évoluer très vite le
plan de relance l'initiative franco
allemande
la proposition de la commission sont des
choses qui étaient impensables il ya six
mois vous serez sans doute d'accord
toutes les 2 face à la chine et les
états unis portant haut les valeurs de
l'union européenne et ce seront les mots
de la fin merci à toutes les deux des
revenus sur ce plateau vous pouvez voir
et revoir cette émission replay sur le
site internet de public scène
à très bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures européennes
[Musique]